WE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
JOINING ME TO DISPUTE OR BACK UP
MY STATEMENTS, SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT TOGETHER, YOU
MORE THAN ME, YOU ARE A LITTLE
BIT OLDER.
>> OUR SUPPLY CHAIN WE LEARNED
DURING COVID WAS CHINA-CENTRIC.
CHIPS.
WE JUST PASSED A BIG CHIPS BILL.
WHETHER YOU MAKE A REFRIGERATOR,
TELEVISION OR F-35, CHIPS.
90% OF THE CHIP MANUFACTURING IN
THE WORLD IS DONE IN TAIWAN.
THE LAST THING YOU WOULD WANT
CHINA TO DO IS TAKE OVER TAIWAN
AND HAVE A MONOPOLY IN THE CHIP
INDUSTRY.
BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION IS DUMB
AND WEAK.
INSTEAD OF IMPOSING SANCTIONS
WHEN HE BUILT UP HIS ARMY ON THE
BORDER ON UKRAINE, WE DIDN'T
WANT TO PRO SHOWED PUTIN.
WHAT ARE WE DOING IN TAIWAN?
WE NEED TO GIVE MORE MILITARY
AND ECONOMIC AID TO TAIWAN.
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
WORKING TO KILL THE BILL.
BRIAN: THEY DON'T WANT TO
PROVOKE THEIR GOLIATH NEIGHBOR.
HAVE THEY CHANGED THEIR STANCE?
>> 63 F-16s ARE GOING TO
TAIWAN.
SO THE TAIWANESE ARE READY TO
FIGHT FOR THEIR FREEDOM.
IT WILL BE TOUGH TO INVADE THAT
ISLAND.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE
FACE FREEDOM.
THEY WILL FIGHT LIKE TIGERS NOT
TO GIVE IT UP.
THE BILL WITH SENATOR MENENDEZ,
WE PUTS SANCTIONS ON CHINA.
THIS IS A STRONG STATEMENT
AGAINST CHINA AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS UNDERCUTTING
OUR EFFORTS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS IN
DENIAL ABOUT THE RISE OF QUIED
IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE HAVE A BROKEN BORDER.
HOW EASY WOULD IT BE FOR
TERRORISTS TO COME THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND KILL A BUNCH
OF US.
BRIAN: I WANT YOU TO HEAR FROM
CHRIS WRAY.
HERE IS WHAT CHRIS WRAY SAID
ABOUT CHINA.
>> DIRECTOR WRAY, WHO IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT GEOPOLITICAL
FOE THE NEWT FACES IN THE NEXT
DECADE?
>> THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF
CHINA AND SPECIFICALLY THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
BRIAN: IT'S THE HACKING, IT'S
THE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WE HAVE TO GET THEM ON THEIR
HEELS.
IS THERE A PLAN IN PLACE TO
START COMPREHENSIVELY
IDENTIFYING THEM?
>> THE FBI DIRECTOR SAID EVERY
12 HOURS THEY OPEN UP A CASE
AGAINST CHINESE ESPIONAGE.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THE BORDER IS
COMPLETELY BROKEN, IT'S NOT
SECURE.
THIS BILL WE ARE GOING TO VOTE
ON IN A DAY OR SO WILL NOT
REDUCE INFLATION.
THERE IS NO PLAN TO SECURE OUR
BORDER IN THE FACE OF RISING
TERRORISM.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
CYBER TECH AND ESPIONAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO DIRECTOR WRAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO DOMESTIC GROWTH
AND POSSIBLE FAR IT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS KILLING
PROSPERITY.
WHEN IT COMES TO GEOPOLITICAL
THREATS, THEY ARE WEAK AND DUMB.
BRIAN: TIME TO TAKE
MANUFACTURING, PUT IT IN CENTRAL
AMERICA.
LET'S ATTACK BOTH PROBLEMS AT
ONCE AND LET THEM BUILD.
AL-ZAWAHIRI GETS BLOWN UP ON A
--ON A BALCONY IN KABUL.
>> I APPLAUD THE KILLING OF THIS
GUY BECAUSE HE HELPED PLAN 9/11.
HE WAS LIVING IN A HOUSE OF THE
NUMBER TWO GUY OF THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT.
CLEARLY THEIR RELATIONSHIP IS
BACK AGAIN.
BEFORE 9/11 THE TALIBAN ALLOWED
AL~QAEDA TO ROAM FREELY IN
AFGHANISTAN, THAT'S WHAT LED TO
9/11.
TRAINING CAMPS ARE RISING AND
THE BORDER IS COMPLETELY BROKEN.
THIS IS A PERFECT STORM FOR
ANOTHER 9/11, AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IN MY VIEW IS NOT
TAKING CORRECTIVE ACTION.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE OUR INFLATION
PROBLEMS WORSE.
THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE.
THE TALIBAN KNEW ABOUT
AL-ZAWAHIRI AND THIS INFLATION
ACT IS A